this shiny metal is
constantly in a liquid state
[Music]
this is mercury
we normally see this metal in tiny
quantities
but what would happen if we took
thousands of liters of it
and filled a pool entirely with liquid
mercury
and then what if you jumped into it
what would liquid mercury do to your
skin
[Music]
how would it affect your brain
[Music]
and could you swim in it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you jumped into a pool full of liquid
mercury
mercury is more than 13 times
denser than water and substantially
heavier
it's also much thicker with greater
surface tension than water as well
so what would it feel like if you jumped
into a pool of this liquid metal
[Music]
before we fill up our pool with liquid
mercury
we're going to need to find a lot of it
mercury is a rare metal found in earth's
crust and
due to it being so rare it's also quite
expensive
filling an entire pool full of liquid
mercury
would cost hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars
once you've acquired all your liquid
mercury you can now
fill up your pool but due to liquid
mercury being so much heavier than water
you'd need to make sure that your pool
is reinforced
to handle such a heavy weight
okay that was very time consuming and
expensive but we finally have our pool
full of liquid mercury and now it's time
to jump in
and as soon as you jumped in you'd be
met with a
thud rather than a satisfying splash
due to the density of the liquid mercury
you wouldn't sink
down into the pool instead your
feet would be submerged and that's about
it
if you were to dive head first into the
pool from a
three meter ladder then you'd probably
get
knocked out from the impact of hitting
the liquid mercury
but just because you don't get injured
from the jump itself
that doesn't mean you'd be safe
assuming you jumped into the pool with
standard swim attire you
wouldn't be wearing any shoes this means
at first
your feet would be making direct contact
with the liquid mercury
[Music]
this would cause severe burns and
irritation
and this would only worsen as you'd most
likely lose
balance from just standing on your feet
it would be like standing on watery
jello and
would be incredibly difficult to balance
on
so you'd most likely fall on your back
or stomach
you still wouldn't sink in but now your
whole body would be covered with the
liquid mercury
[Music]
and the longer it stays on your skin the
worse it would get
prolonged exposure to liquid mercury
would lead to it getting absorbed by
your skin
and once that happens the mercury would
make its way to your organs
including your brain
and this is where mercury poisoning
would set in
and if you think you could avoid all
this by wearing a wetsuit and
keep mercury from touching your skin at
all think again
that's because just inhaling the liquid
mercury fumes would poison you
sometimes even faster than just touching
it
the longer you stay in the pool the
worse it would get
you would start with a headache and
you'd start to feel woozy
at this point you should probably get
out of the pool
but even if you managed to survive this
long
this much exposure to liquid mercury
would stay with you
for a long time if not forever
over time the symptoms of mercury
poisoning would include
speech difficulties lack of coordination
and
even vision loss and
if you didn't manage to get out of the
pool you'd
pass out and die from the metals fumes
okay so jumping into a pool full of
liquid mercury
is a terrible idea but what if
instead of just liquid mercury we could
turn
any metal into a liquid
well that's a story for another
what if